you didn't see that coming
everything about one division is that we
can to see what an ideal life for one
that vision actually looks like
[Music]
we're gonna make the first scary MCU
bill
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie we got
to talk about Quicksilver dr. strange to
multiverse of madness in The Scarlet
Witch show there's news about
Quicksilver coming back for scenes
during one division in dr. strange too
so we'll break it down
we're doing a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Doctor
Strange two theory on the video there's
a whole bunch they've already explained
about what's going on during the series
with whan division and how that builds
into the plot of Doctor Strange too
because it basically starts out with Tom
King's vision run which I'll explain in
a second because they're making some big
changes because this is all based around
Scarlet Witch instead of being based
around vision like the original comic
series I'm so excited we get to play
around with like a totally different
genre with these characters that we have
based in reality here on this planet
earth where it could also be exploded by
aliens all the time or whatever that
reality and we faced it there and now
we're gonna morph them into a sitcom
universe and get to be stylized we're
gonna play around it's actors we got to
play around with time period like it's
just gonna be a wild ride and then it's
gonna morph back into the familiar world
that we know of Marvel so all this
Quicksilver multiverse multiple
dimensions business starts with the
blond division TV show as scarlet
witch's power continues to grow just
like it has through all the Marvel films
her life slowly starts to unravel while
she's trying to give herself the normal
life she feels like she deserves after
all the loss and pain she's suffered
what she thinks is a normal life though
her idealized version of normal yet
remembered that she grew up in sokovia
in this war-torn country so her idea of
normal isn't the same as say like your
average persons that's where you get to
the Tom King vision run with some
changes during that story it was all
about visions desire to lead what his
synthetic mind viewed as a normal life
so he builds himself literally builds
himself a family of synthezoids and
tries to live a 1950's post-war Norman
Rockwell fantasy of the American life
like the term the American Dream having
a nuclear family mom dad 2.5 children
two-car garage a house in the
suburbs the battle is over time to
settle down and live the American dream
that's why everything on this show this
special teaser preview that they
released looks like it's right out of
the 1950s the TV even the logo of the
show looks like the appliance logos from
the 1950s this is all because that's
what advertising during the 1950's told
you what the ideal life was supposed to
look like and because in this case its
scarlet witch's frame of reference and
vision is still dead this is what the
reality that she built for herself
looks like the really big Easter Egg for
all that you may have spotted in that
teaser at the beginning of the video is
that at the beginning of it when you see
the static like someone is changing
channels on an old CRT TV from the 1950s
until you land on the station with the
Wanda vision logo that's basically an
Easter Egg for Scarlet Witch using her
powers to bend reality till she builds
herself a perfect family life and it all
comes into focus
Lego we've landed on the reality that I
finally want cobbled together from all
these other realities that gets into
concepts like the multiverse multiple
dimensions remember the plot of Scarlet
Witch and visions Wanda vision show is
all about setting up Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness which
literally has multiverse going mad in
the title the reason why Scarlet Witch
is using her powers to bring vision back
is because they originally intended to
settle down together and try to live a
normal family alive Thanos took that
away from her
one of the famous lines from Avengers
endgame you took everything from me I
don't even know who you are so the
beginning of the Wanda vision show is
her trying to take that all back for
herself even if it means screwing with
multiple realities to do it
fear the thing they haven't addressed in
a major way is her grief over losing her
brother Quicksilver there was talk of
bringing him back for an Avengers
endgame cameo but like a billion other
ideas that got left on the cutting room
floor just because there wasn't room for
it so while they use the show to allow
her to process all of her feelings about
vision dying it's also going to allow
her to process losing her brother
Quicksilver which is where you get to
Quicksilver cameo including him
referencing him in some meaningful but
brief way also a big plus right now
Aaron taylor-johnson the actor hasn't
been doing a whole lot of films the last
couple of years he's in Christopher
Nolan's Tennant movie which is coming
out next summer but otherwise he's not
super busy
it sounds like he would be available for
a1 division in dr. strange to cameo
they're not going to be shooting one
division til later this year there's
already been construction on some of the
sets there's this gazebo that's part of
their suburban house that they live in
that's designed to look a little bit
like someone's mind the metaphor that
they're going here is that it's a little
bit like scarlet witch's mind because
this is a false reality that she's
slowly building for herself the actual
plot of the Wanda vision show will
follow similar beats to the Tom King
vision run as it builds into Doctor
Strange - starts out with them living
their quote-unquote normal life you know
what they think is a normal life but
things quickly start to unravel around
Scarlet Witch and it turns into a big
adventure series as outside forces start
to take advantage of what Scarlet Witch
is doing with reality right now
nightmare is the rumored villain for
Doctor Strange - so think about Scarlet
Witch this way she builds a false
reality for herself and nightmare from
the fear dimension starts to turn that
happy dream of hers that she's creating
into a nightmare a metaphorical
nightmare but then because it's a big
Marvel project with tons of superpowers
it turns into a real physical nightmare
that has her fighting for her life that
would explain why Doctor Strange has to
get involved because Scarlet Witch is
reality warping probably allows
nightmare to enter our dimension and
start preying on everyone Doctor Strange
starts to have waking nightmares and
senses some serious [ __ ] is going down
wait a minute why am I having waking
nightmares I'm the sorcerer supreme
something doesn't feel right
spider-man far from home theory - that
doesn't have anything to do with him
leaving the MCU when Talos Nick Fury
tells Peter the Doctor Strange is
unavailable to help with the Mysterio
problem all they have to do is say that
the plot of Doctor Strange - is
happening at the same time as spider-man
far from home in Doctor Strange was
unavailable because he and Scarlet Witch
were trapped in the fear dimension by
nightmare the reason why everyone thinks
that nightmare is the villain is because
the director wouldn't stop talking about
nightmare being the villain of the
sequel while ago in interviews like the
character of nightmare and the concept
that the nightmare nightmare realm is a
dimension
I always thought that was one of the
that's early that's like in the first
strange tale it
I think that's in the introductory Epps
episode of Doctor Strange and I always
loved that well we decided not to do
that just because that's a bit of a
complex idea to try to introduce
everything that we do introduce and
introduce the idea of nightmares
themselves as being another dimension
I hope somewhere down the line we get to
explore that except I think that's a
super cool concept the whole concept of
the nightmare villain is that he's one
of the fear lords he's a contemporary of
people like Mephisto who technically was
a fox character but now because they
have the Fox characters they could
actually use Mephisto as a future Doctor
Strange villain nightmare rules from a
fear dimension in invades people's
dreams while they sleep but sometimes
things happen to allow him to penetrate
the waking world in our dimension that's
where you really get to these big huge
battles with Doctor Strange but it
sounds like because scarlet witch's
reality warping powers are growing they
said that they're going to reveal why
she's called The Scarlet Witch during
the Wanda vision show in Doctor Strange
- that sounds like they're getting into
full-blown x-men version of Scarlet
Witch there's also a big theory that
they might use these series to start
explaining mutants in the MCU because
they have to find a way to reconcile how
Scarlet Witch can have her origin story
that she had in the MCU but also be a
genuine mutant from the x-men comics
before all this x-men fox business they
just called them quote unquote enhanced
people but now because of that deleted
scene from the first Iron Man film where
Nick Fury mentions mutants we know that
they've been planning on using mutants
this whole time since back in phase one
I have to deal with the spoiled brat
doesn't play well with others who wants
to keep all his toys to himself that
still blows my mind that they almost put
that in the movie they would have been
sued out of existence but originally
they shot that with the intention of
putting it in Iron Man 1 so they were
planning on x-men and spider-man
crossover from the very beginning I've
already done an Easter Egg video for
what that original x-men Avengers
crossover would have looked like at the
time now so much has happened the x-men
franchise got dragged through the mud
since then so a lot of people are going
to be recast when new x-men show up but
it's a fascinating video that also
includes a
Tobey Maguire version of spider-man
crossing over with the Avengers so you
can click here to watch that and you can
click here for my new black widow teaser
and news about Iron Man coming back
during Marvel phase 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]